hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number
131 which is prime it is indeed
it is indeed i don't know if that
matters to anyone else but it matters to
us at a very deep level for some reason
that i don't even know but
um
i am dr brett weinstein this is dr
heather heing rhymes with flying um i'm
going to try to do better at orienting
people to the podcast just because who
knows how much time we have left on this
planet and i think doing better is uh is
one of the things that we can we can
shoot for yes and who is this in your
lap this is fairfax he is um one of the
cats who um
lives around here we feed them so they
stick around is that how it works well i
don't know that's not how i've noticed
the relationship
yes but for those of you just listening
uh he has snuggled up on
on brett and uh
may be in for the duration at this point
yes for those of you who have just
happened by by accident i should point
out
that uh we are married and not only that
but we are married to each other indeed
yes yeah we are we even have children we
we do and uh
one of the things i think the final
segment that we'll talk about a little
bit today is fatherhood uh and
uh in part because tomorrow is father's
day uh we are recording this on we're
live streaming on june 18th
and yesterday we attended the high
school graduation of our of our
firstborn uh so a lot lots of sort of
parenting and transitions to think about
think about right now yes i should just
say as long as we're on the topic that
uh this is zach we are talking about
who's also the producer of the podcast
and i i know i speak for you too but i
am extremely proud of zach and it turns
out it has very little to do with what
went on in high school
and uh presumably that is often the case
that is often the case uh you and i met
in high school we were just friends
there in fact i just found
our senior my senior yearbook which was
which was fun and also to see what you
wrote to me back then
um
so i actually had
an extraordinary high school experience
um yours was somewhat different you you
came to the high school that i had been
at since actually seventh grade um in
11th
but in general people do not end up
having the formative experiences or the
friendships in high school that it feels
like at the time is everything and
all-encompassing
so yeah i got a soul mate so i feel good
about high school but other than that i
mean there were some some good point
points in high school but uh it was uh
it was challenging yeah and you know
this it's it's the time of life and it's
also increasingly the way it's done the
way school is done
the way school is done unto
the young people who are graduating as
opposed to
allowing them to
understand how much ability they have to
make the world that they are going to
inherit that they want to see i think
you can tighten that a little bit school
is done
i'm not sure that's entirely true but um
nor do you actually you just thought
that was a cute thing it's a reboot yeah
it it i'm not sure we can resurrect it
in its current form it's gonna need you
know
a fresh sheet of paper maybe a new
foundation and you know build up from
there yeah
um so today we're gonna also talk about
uh why everything is labeled the wrong
way
and
why you're angry with the wrong people
and a little bit about baby formula
possibly and then uh fathers and uh
something about what father fatherhood
means
but first logistics
uh we follow these live streams with a
live q a you can ask questions for the
live q a starting now at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
we have of course our book a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century is out in both
we got it in spanish but i don't have it
here i only have the french still
sitting here so it's out in english
and it's now out in spanish and french
as well
both of which are available on amazon
if you're watching on youtube there's a
live chat going on on odyssey right now
so you can jump over there where
we will not be censored we will not be
censored on our seats so there's a
there's a very strong reason to go over
there
we also this week
on our store at uh
store.darkerspodcast.org we have a cool
new shirt
we have a cool new shirt so let me pull
it up and then there it is actually um i
don't know why um
zach you can now show my screen i don't
know why when i pull it up it shows
all the text on the store shows in
spanish it doesn't matter
but there's the shirt
yep it reads for those of you
listening and not watching it says le
tour de france
it's like bike racing on steroids
and i believe the explanatory text says
yes it's rather a lot like bike racing
on steroids or something to that effect
yes anyway highly explanatory i would
suggest if this shirt strikes you as
something that you want you might get it
sooner rather than later because
although clearly we are well within
protected bounds
uh as a parody and not using the logo of
uh litura de france um we have no idea
how the corporate gods will view this
and we have had instances in the past
where we dare i say it made fun of
youtube community guidelines and
teespring leapt to their rescue damsel
in distress as it as youtube was and uh
so only a few of those shirts made it
into the world
i am hoping that this one uh will last a
good long time because frankly this one
gets relevant each and every year right
about july yeah yeah we're introducing
this now because the the
we're going to start for those of you
who are interested in bikes and bike
racing you're going to have been
beginning to hear about the tour de
france for this year right around now
right yeah right i've actually not run
into it but then i i don't run into a
lot of things that are happening in the
media because i can't take it i have i
have run into i have to say um there's a
part of me that is actually a bit
fascinated by bike racing
i am not fascinated by the tour de
france it is
everything about bike racing that it
shouldn't but anyway so there's one i
mean as long as as long as we're talking
about bike racing and we've got this
fine shirt up on the screen where you
can find at uh you can go to what was it
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
um
there's a bike race
that you that is kind of in some ways
similar to the tour de france that you
actually do appreciate it's like the
real tour de france
it is uh the paris breast paris race
okay which is so it's a round trip it's
a round it's not there it's not actually
it's there it's there and back and it's
it's part of a tradition called
randineering and the idea is that unlike
i mean the exact opposite of the tour
in the paris breast paris race you are
responsible for navigating you are
responsible for doing your own mechanic
work so effectively you know unlike the
tour where you will ride a fragile bike
and there will be a car with a
replacement bike should your bike fail
on you and you'll have a team of
mechanics um where you don't in fact you
are benefited for not having thought
about tolerances not having thought
about trade-offs
and whereas with the paris breast paris
race that's what it's called it just
called that um you need to be thinking
about tolerances and trade-offs and
actually the entire you know it's a
little bit like um
skiing uh with the help of a lift uh and
yeah you know and and all the help that
you get um that way and having to get up
to the top of the mountain yourself and
earn your earn your thrills right this
is more iditarod like and you know
everything matters like how you eat what
you carry meaning what equipment you
carry yeah um you know
how much you understand about your bike
you know if you yeah you know can you
make it on one break if you bust a cable
you can't repair it or whatever so
anyway yes it tests the the full cyclist
rather than just you know a pair of legs
on a bike right um so anyway uh that's a
cool race i it's not run every year but
uh
anyway so yes
this shirt is available should you want
one yeah you know where to find it so
yeah go get yourself one okay you can
take you can take that off now if you
like zach
this week in natural selections which is
my sub stack
i i posted a reprint of my 2020 letter
wiki conversation with abigail schreier
in which we discussed
what is going on with the incredible
rise in
uh in girls declaring themselves trans
in particular and that has been a
conversation that has been that has been
well received ever since we wrote it a
little less than two years ago uh as a
as a series of three letters each back
and forth
uh and letter wiki unfortunately uh is
no longer as of about a week and a half
ago and so it's it's up there now freely
available if you're interested and of
course abigail schweier is uh is
extraordinary she's the author of i
didn't write it down is it error
concealable differences no no no no no
it's uh irreparable damage damage gosh
that was terrible um
no i'm gonna look it up we're gonna find
out i'm gonna look it up at the point
that you're talking and then i will come
back and fix that all right okay um we
are supported by our audience as uh as
are so many now
we appreciate you subscribing and liking
and sharing both these main videos on
youtube and odyssey and then when it's
out on spotify and everywhere and on the
audio where actually the vast majority
of our audience is audio only
but we have clips channels which are
video only
that are youtube and odyssey and you
know please do subscribe to the channels
and like the videos and share them share
them far and wide
uh youtube as many of you know
demonetized us completely back in
last summer and that cut out a
tremendous amount of our income
so we appreciate
all the support that we get including
the
incredible
fan mail that we get every every week
but if you are in a position to do so we
appreciate financial support as well of
course so you can join either of our
patreons
where in on either of them you can
access our tremendous discord server
about which
they say you can engage in honest
conversations about difficult topics
join a book club even unwind with
virtual happy hours and karaoke young or
old left or right there's a spot for you
around the campfire we actually just
meant met yesterday
another person in her 80s who's a fan of
the podcast so there really is an
incredible range of people i don't know
that she's undiscorded ask her
but
incredible range of people who are
tuning in paying attention
um valuing open conversation without
without disrespect and without
belittlement and you can find that on
the discord server which you can access
by joining either of our patreons yes um
people are even meeting in person we
have again been invited to a meet that
we can't go to because we are
already occupied but nonetheless people
are meeting in person they're really
enjoying these things
um you know
the the vaccinated the unvaccinated they
mix as if the same species it's it's an
incredible vibe
almost like it's 2019 right
almost
those are the good old days strange yes
strange strange um yeah also of course
on my patreon you can get access to our
monthly private q a which right now the
uh the session is open to ask questions
uh at the 11 tiers you can go on there
and ask ask questions there for us to
address in
a couple of
weeks i think are you both you and
fairfax now looking at the window at
crows we're watching a squirrel a
squirrel okay yeah squirrel fight yeah
that's that's good stuff we saw five of
them outside today i didn't even know we
had five squirrels luckily yeah fairfax
and i did um
and then you have
you have a few conversations associated
with your patreon every month as well on
the first saturday and sunday of the
month
all right um as well we have sponsors
for which we are very grateful and uh we
only accept uh ad sponsorship from
products that we actually truly vouch
for so there's three as always here we
go
all right our first sponsor this week is
eight sleep and i wanna tell you a
little bit about what eight sleep does
imagine you have two people with
different temperature requirements one
of them likes to have the room cool so
they can shed heat and one of them likes
to have a little hot well if you set it
a little hot then the person who likes
to be a little cool can't do anything
about it because the most you can do is
take the covers off you and there's no
way to radiate heat if the room is
warming you but if you have an eight
sleep unit then what happens is it
actually can pull heat out and radiate
it elsewhere and it can cool you down
arbitrarily leaving the person who likes
the bed hot having their preference and
the person who needs it to be cool in
order to sleep having their preference
and it's just
it's a game changer likes versus needs
yeah likes versus well here's the reason
i say likes
versus needs is that the person because
you're the guy who thinks you need the
thing that you need no i i think i think
it's it's more honorable than that um
the person who likes it hotter
can use more blankets the person who
likes it cooler can't do anything at the
point the room is too hot to radiate to
so
so anyway it is kind of a
an asymmetrical situation but
nonetheless nonetheless this object
allows you to pull heat out and radiate
it somewhere else just the same way your
car takes heat out of the engine block
and radiates it out the radiator it's a
great system
um your refrigerator right and your
refrigerator which then puts heat into
your kitchen even in the summer which
makes no sense and we could fix that but
we don't no we don't yet i digress um
the pod pro cover by eight sleep is the
most advanced solution on the market for
thermoregulation
you can add the cover to any mattress
and start sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
fahrenheit or as hot as 110 yikes
not that we recommend either of those
extremes the temperature of the cover
will adjust each side of the bed based
on your sleep stages biometrics and
bedroom temperature reacting dynamically
to create the optimal sleeping
environment eight sleep users fall
asleep 32 faster reduce sleep
interruptions by 40 and get more restful
sleep overall
and with 30 percent more deep sleep on
average that uh restorative sleep will
likely help with physical recovery
hormone regulation and mental clarity
finally the alarm feature which can wake
you with temperature change or slight
chest level vibrations
is so much gentler than any standard
alarm
we are we're both a little skeptical and
now we're totally sold we are surprised
at how much we appreciate this bed go to
eight sleep dot com slash dark horse
that's
e-i-g-h-t-s-l-e-e-p dot com slash dark
horse to check out the pod pro cover and
save 150 at checkout eight sleep ships
to the usa canada and the united kingdom
awesome our second sponsor this week
will be well familiar to regular viewers
and listeners it's vevo barefoot shoes
made for feet most shoes are made for
someone's idea of what feet should be
rather than actual feet
vivos are made by people who know feet
these shoes are as i've said many times
before here and off air as well a
revelation we love them they're beyond
comfortable the tactile feedback from
the surfaces you're walking on is
amazing they cause no pain because there
are no pressure points forcing your feet
into odd positions they're quite
fantastic
our feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution we evolved to walk
move and run barefoot but modern shoes
that are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
health crisis which one in which people
move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength foot strength
food strength increases by 60 in a
matter of months just by walking around
in them the number of people wearing
vivo barefoots is growing we keep on
seeing more and more people wearing them
which is a sign that people are actually
adopting
footwear that is good for them as
opposed to just on the basis of that's
fashionable at the moment and
ever ever choosing
uh something on which you depend so
highly based on fashion is going to be a
mistake but especially when you're
talking about shoes once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop
vivo has vivobarefoot has a great range
of footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity hiking training everyday
wear there are certified b corp
pioneering regenerative business
principles and their footwear is
produced using sustainably sourced
material
natural and recycled with the aim to
protect the natural world so you can run
wild in it
go to vivobarefoot.com darkhorse to get
an exclusive offer of 20 off
additionally all new customers get a
hundred day free trial so you can see if
you love them as much as we do that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t
dot com slash darkhorse
and finally our final sponsor this week
is all form a company that makes
terrific custom sofas we like them so
much we have two of them
we make what makes the sofa so terrific
for a fraction of the cost of
traditional sofas you can customize size
layout fabric and color
they do arm chairs and love seats all
the way up to an eight-seat sectional
and you can start small and buy more
seats later on without needing to get a
whole new sofa
all form sofas are delivered directly to
your home free and fast and assembly is
easy we started with one beautiful
sectional all-form sofa and whiskey
leather it's soft and supple and warm
unlike a lot of leather we all pile onto
it to watch movies some evenings it
looks gorgeous and it's incredibly
inviting and comfortable a rare
combination we liked it so much we got a
second one as i said
also some listeners have asked if all
form holds up to pets it does we've got
one dog a labrador who has never let me
clip her claws and two cats who do
but uh that's a lot of animals for one
couch the leather that all form uses is
about 20 thicker than typical furniture
leather and we see no signs uh no sign
of wear despite the fact that both our
cats and our dog lie on the couch many
evenings and if you prefer fabric all
form fabrics are three and a half times
more durable than the industry standard
for heavy duty fabrics so their fabrics
are going to hold up really well to pets
as well
finally they offer a forever warranty
literally forever to find your perfect
sofa check out allform.com darkhorse all
form is offering 20 off all orders for
our listeners at allform.com
darkhorse
all right
well
you brett wanted to start this week by
talking about why everything is labeled
in the inverse yes and uh i should say
we didn't mention at the top um there
are a couple of podcasts that i did in
bath that are out now and actually they
fit perfectly this topic so robert
malone
sat with me you can find that one on
spotify that's not on youtube because
youtube can't handle the truth youtube
cannot handle the truth and their uh
their uh community guidelines folks
believe you can't handle the truth um
garrett vandenbosch that one is out as
of two days ago um that one is out on
youtube and spotify i believe
that one is already out
it is already out yes um both of these
are and of course neil oliver was the
first one that you did in england and
there's two more coming right there's
two more coming and then there was
another one that i recorded this week uh
on a slightly different topic
but in any case um all of these are
cases
in which we are wrestling with the
question of what the truth is and what
it isn't and many of us have noticed
that the labels on these things seem to
be flipped at an incredible rate in
modern times it's not like most of what
is uh discussed by official sources is
right and then every so often there's
something over which we disagree and
some thing that has been labeled wrong
turns out to be right if you look at
topics like
the covid pandemic and
the public health reaction to it you
will find the labels are just simply
reversed right and that is uh
a conspicuous pattern because if we were
just simply confused you wouldn't expect
the labels to reverse you would expect
it to be noisy and contentious and you'd
get a hodgepodge so um examples of
labels here that you're thinking of well
uh let's just say if you were trying to
navigate what to do for your family in
light of
covet right let's say like us you
believe covet to be a dangerous and
destructive
pathogen and you're concerned about
preventing it and you're concerned uh
about
preventing transmission and you're
concerned about reducing the hazard that
the pathogen
poses to you and your family
well the question is if you go to the
cdc or the fda or the who or any of the
official sources if you go to the new
york times the washington post
you'll find the the answer is very clear
that these uh
vaccines which is the wrong term and
increasingly
people have begun to understand why this
is this is a matter of significance you
might say that they are transfective
agents
they are certainly inoculations um but
vaccine is not a good definition for
them but nonetheless it's not the right
it's not the word that should be applied
to them but absent that word being
applied to them it would have been much
harder to get so many people on board
right that's that's just the thing so
labeling them uh as vaccines is a case
in which you've got um
the standard outlets all describing
these things in terms that are
inaccurate um the
value of these things was inaccurately
described from the beginning of their uh
efficacy if we're talking about in the
trial phase or their effectiveness once
they are released at preventing you from
contracting the disease preventing you
from transmitting the disease is
actually extremely low
but we are told that we must take them
in order to prevent the spread of this
dangerous disease that's uh
misinformation masquerading as
information
whereas we are told that repurposed
drugs um i won't mention the names so we
can leave them here on youtube but you
are free to infer that i am talking
about the same compounds that we have
been arguing about for many many months
paste
walls of paste
um i think you should get the human
version but nonetheless there are
multiple repurposed drugs
that
uh
clearly have high efficacy not only have
they been successfully incorporated by
the doctors who have been most effective
at treating patients
uh with covid they've been deployed
successfully around the world have uh
are clearly implicated in the crash of
waves of
covid that took place in places like
uttar pradesh
this is good crash we're talking about
right so in any case what you've got is
actually effective
pharmaceuticals that we are told are
snake oil and we have something that
isn't a vaccine which we are told is a
vaccine that doesn't do the two most
important things that it would need to
do in order to control the pandemic and
to explain why they would be mandated
which is to prevent you from contracting
the disease and prevent you from passing
it on
in other words what you've got is the
exact inverse of a recipe for protecting
yourself right you could have done the
right thing for your family if only you
had known that you should tune out the
new york times the washington post uh
the cdc the fda the who
um all the major universities right and
so this is a problem because for most of
us we are not equipped
to look at the entire range of
institutions and say they've all got it
wrong i mean even my voicing that sounds
perfectly insane what are the chances
that all the institutions got it wrong
and if they did all get it wrong
my point is we have to now go backwards
and say well
what could possibly explain that
yeah
one of the issues and
i i
i don't think i'm going to step on any
of the toes that you are about to put
into the argument that didn't work at
all today
is
that when it's all the institutions
it it raises the question of how is that
possible it could be all of them
and most people will look at that and
say well it's just so obvious it's just
so obvious that they have all come to
that and back in their mind whether or
not they are conscious of this maybe
whether or not people are actually
statistically sophisticated enough to
recognize that what they are imagining
is everyone came to this idea
independently right
whereas if it's really all the
institutions there's
there's now a reasonable chance that
actually that's a bunch of
non-independent data points
and that and you know we know that you
know the media aren't doing original
science that they have to accept the
authority from someone largely even
so-called science journalists largely
are not doing as much of the sort of
assessment of the signs that they're
reporting on as they should be
but at the point that there is
uniformity of agreement across all of
the domains
then you really do have to wonder about
whether or not the independence of the
data points and therefore the
independence of the press and academia
and everything is in fact present where
it it needs to be
right and
you know it should also be obvious to
people as they look at
the
supposed consensus in front of them that
those who have departed from the
consensus have had terrible things
happen to them right we all of us who
have departed from the consensus who are
professionally trained in any regard
have been dismissed as cranks and kooks
and worse we've been called grifters and
all sorts of things and so the point is
look you know there is an incentive to
stick with the conventional narrative
and then the consensus is uh trotted out
as evidence that uh the the the pattern
is very clear and anybody who you know
knows how to do the analysis will reach
the same conclusion that the cdc and the
fda and the who and the new york times
and everybody else has reached right
but the point is
when you see an intense campaign that
punishes people for stepping out of line
then you have to ask the question
what you know
how
how durable how meaningful is that a
potemkin consensus right is that a
paper-thin consensus born of the fact
that all of those who are capable of
seeing the problem with it are afraid to
say what they can see and in any case
we've talked about that many times what
i wanted to do here is introduce an
element that
has increasingly been uh
haunting me and i realized as i was
thinking about how to introduce it
but this stretches
um elements of this analysis stretch way
back uh for me and i wanted to point out
something zach i sent you a couple of
papers did you get them
well i will just describe the papers
while zach is looking for them
the two papers are papers that i
published one with david lottie on the
evolution of morality and in that paper
we make an argument that there is a
tension between two kinds of
evolutionary success
right
uh yeah you want to put up the lottie
paper
better angels
um
so the two types of success
and i must say that i do have one major
regret with this paper
we used the word group
when what we really meant was lineage
and so in any case people can look at
this paper but i would implore you yes
lineages are groups but they are more
than that and i wish we had used a
different term but nonetheless here's
the paper and
the argument that we make in the paper
is that you have an evolutionary tension
between two kinds of success one is the
success of competition within your
lineage or your population or yes your
group
and so you can get ahead by uh out
competing others who are effectively in
your same boat
and then the second kind of success has
to do with how successful your boat is
against competing populations
and
um that will come into play here
um
in in a second
the other paper that is relevant here
you want to put up so i can actually it
looks like i can pull them up
in a way that
okay the other paper is the telomere
paper
that you those who have listened to the
podcast many times will have
occasionally heard us reference this is
the paper in which
i argue with my uh co-author here debbie
seasick
that
we evolve to grow feeble and inefficient
with age we senesce um as the
unavoidable downside of a cancer
protection element of our uh of our
physiology and
and uh cellular makeup
and the reason that this is relevant
here is that
there's a long story which you can go
back to eric's portal podcast with me if
you want to know the the gory details of
the academic history behind this paper
but i had a collaborator
when i started to do the work on
telomeres i ran into a
fact that made no sense given what i was
coming to understand and if the fact was
wrong then a lot of things fell into
place and if the fact was right i was my
hypothesis was dead in the water and so
i stared a lot at this fact and tried to
understand what might be wrong with it
the fact was that mice were all
understood to have long telomeres and
the argument that i make ultimately
published in this paper that you just
saw
is that those long telomeres ought to
imbue those mice with the capacity for
great longevity and mice are very
short-lived and so the fact of mice
having long telomeres was a an outlier
that could not be explained away unless
something very strange had happened and
what i realized over time was that there
was reason to believe that the colonies
in which we breed laboratory mice had
exerted a selective effect that had
massively elongated their telomeres and
that what the field had concluded that
mice or maybe even rodents all have long
telomeres was just simply wrong and that
the reason that nobody figured that out
was that they were all getting their
mice from the same source and because
they got them from the same source every
time people looked at
mouse telomeres they found the same
thing which is mouse telomeres are ultra
long so laboratory mice having been bred
under very particular
selective breeding protocols have long
telomeres
which is quite different from mice have
long telomeres or even worse rodents
have long telomeres right and what it
takes is an evolutionary perspective and
in this case what it took was an
evolutionary theorist but it you know it
takes evolutionary thinking to say oh
actually if we move an organism from its
environment into a lab and make a whole
lot more of them over a lot of
generations we may have effects that we
weren't counting on and of course we've
seen that in the last two years as well
with regard to this this virus that is
that is
clearly um not a zonatic origin at least
only right yeah
now i will say um i wrote a piece uh
when carol greider the person that i uh
briefly not so briefly collaborated with
i'll tell the story of that in a second
but when she
and her advisor got the nobel prize for
the discovery of the enzyme telomerase
which is the enzyme it's a very
interesting enzyme but an enzyme that
elongates telomeres i wrote a piece that
never got published
about the mouse telomere problem
the title of that piece was of mice and
markets and anyway i'm thinking of
putting it up on
on a sub stack or something but
nonetheless here's the here's the the
upshot
when i realized that
uh
i i believed
that mouse telomeres were probably not
ultra long and that that was laboratory
mice telomeres that were ultra long and
that were misleading the field that was
a hypothesis that had
uh
earth-shattering ramifications if true a
probably false hypothesis that if true
was going to have very serious
implications for drug safety testing for
lots of laboratory science that we do on
topics that are important like cancer
and wound healing and
senescence
and in any case i contacted carol grider
which was somebody i admired from the
literature this is somebody i didn't
know but she was clearly top of the
field
and
i reached out to her i called her on the
phone and i
uh she was very gracious she talked to
me she didn't have to i wasn't any i was
a graduate student at a different
university and yet she talked to me and
when i told her what my hypothesis was
and why i thought it was true she said i
don't think it's true but that's really
interesting and then she gave me uh some
evidence that i had no inkling of which
was that
not only was the pattern in evidence in
mus musculus which was the traditional
laboratory mouse but that there was a
lesser used mouse called muspritis that
also showed the pattern it showed the
pattern differently and the conspicuous
thing that she told me was
how long the telomeres are in masritis
varies based on who you order them from
right which was strongly suggested that
there was something about the laboratory
environment and so
the laboratory environment i believe has
this effect and we now have a powerful
demonstration that it does based on the
fact that those who run
breeding colonies
almost no matter how you set them up
will attempt to increase the number of
mice they produce per unit of effort per
unit of uh time per unit of mouse chow
whatever it is and that the things that
they will do to increase the number of
mice
will inevitably select for younger
animals and it will therefore unbalance
a trade-off between
uh tumor prevention and tissue repair
elongating the telomeres but here's the
reason it shows up here with the things
being mislabeled
carol and her graduate student mike
heyman tested the hypothesis your
hypothesis my hypothesis they tested it
and they found that it was correct they
tested a number of different strains of
uh
basically they weren't wild mice that
they were mice that have been in
captivity for a very short period of
time
and they found that they all had short
telomeres right so eureka
this is really important i now knew that
all of the other stuff that was
dependent on this particular fact not
being what uh
everybody seemed to think it was was
meant that all the rest of what i was
working on was super viable and so i
wanted to publish it and i said carol
where are you going to publish your
laboratory result which i should have
been a co-author on certainly i should
have at least been acknowledged for
providing the hypothesis but nonetheless
i said carol where are you going to
publish this
and you know at this point this is still
somebody who's being collaborative and
and
very decent to me and she said something
that i was too young and naive to
understand at the time
what she said is we're not going to
publish it we're going to keep it in
house
and i did not understand why she had
this very important result it seemed to
me as somebody who understood science to
be an endeavor in which we try to bring
important things into the world that
somebody who had just done a laboratory
test that had revealed that the mice
were using for all of these other things
are broken in some new way that people
did not know that she would be
very eager to bring that into the world
and yet she said no we're gonna keep it
in-house so just just to clarify for
people who aren't on the inside of
academic science and um and you know
breeding protocols you know that leader
thing being a very small subset of
people
this result that the grider lab
generated
pursuing a test of your hypothesis as a
test of your hypothesis revealed that
actually the widespread understanding on
which
was the basis for much of the research
that was being done on things like
telomeres and cancer and senescence at
that point the widespread understanding
which was
mice have long telomeres was
demonstrated to be false they falsified
the widespread understanding which i
don't even know if it was ever called a
hypothesis by testing your hypothesis
that actually um that's going to be
um that's going to be variable by how
long they've been in a lab environment
so what who cares this seems really
arcane
the so what who cares part is actually
as it turns out and as the grider lab
was beginning to understand and as you
certainly were beginning to understand
this will have
remarkably broad effects on things
like drug safety testing and so if you
find this out and you know that your
entire field is actually engaged uh in
doing research based on a flawed
assumption and that flawed assumption is
going to make the results that are being
generated in that field flawed and that
is going to have effects therefore on
drug safety results and therefore on
what drugs get to market and therefore
on what people end up being exposed to
and therefore on people's living or
dying
it is obviously incumbent upon you to
share that with the world and so it is
in that environment that you say to her
where are you going to publish this and
she says we're not going to we're going
to keep it in-house keep it in-house
which i didn't understand but
nonetheless
you know
it was what it was and so i went about
writing
the paper that i wanted to publish and i
uh was going to
cite her work which is obviously vital
to my paper which is a theoretical paper
i was going to cite her as personal
communication
now ultimately
i did discover that she decided to
publish that work and
i won't go too deeply into it but the
question
is why
would she have wanted to keep something
so important
in-house
and the answer i believe i don't know
because at the point that uh i went to
publish my work carol greider
became very strange and pretended that
our interactions had been meaningless uh
and
broke contact
but
nonetheless here's what i now believe i
understand
if you know
that laboratory mice are defective
in a particular way that has
a predictable impact on their ability to
endure damage their their resistance to
tumors all sorts of things
that is potentially a goose that will
continue to lay golden eggs right
because what it means is that you can
predict the results of experiments that
others who are not in on this will not
be able to predict right
and so
i don't know whether that will serve the
research coming out of that particular
lab but will
negatively serve
other research
and other science including drug safety
testing including medicine including the
entire population of the earth who might
be downstream of the effects of what
drugs do and do not get approved yeah i
would say there are two devastating
impacts if that was the logic one
devastating impact is that we test our
pharmaceuticals on these animals and
that the particular defect in question
isn't arbitrary that a mouse with long
telomeres has effectively an infinite
capacity to replace damaged tissue and
has effectively no resistance to
tumors and in fact one of the things
that carol told me on that uh and in our
initial i don't know if it was the first
call that our
several calls that we had
was that essentially all laboratory mice
die of cancer right it's the way they
all die and that's unusual that's not
true for other creatures and it is i
believe clearly the result of this long
telomere phenomenon that the balance
between tumor suppression and tissue
repair has been completely tilted in the
direction of tissue repair which makes
them incredibly cancer prone but what
that also means
is that when you give
a drug that is toxic to these animals to
see how toxic it is
it will have a paradoxical effect if
it's so toxic that it kills the animal
outright
you'll see it but if it's not so toxic
that it kills the animal outright it
will the animal has an preternatural
capacity to replace those tissues and so
the animal will be
much less damaged than a human would be
who has a intense limit on how much
tissue repair they can do
and what's more
because so here's why chemotherapy works
chemotherapy works because cells that
are dividing are more vulnerable than
cells that aren't and in a cancer the
cells are all dividing so they have this
vulnerability so if you give a person
with a cancer
a
toxic substance
you will poison the person and you know
what they say
in in oncology circles is the idea of
chemotherapy is to poison the cancer
faster than you poison the patient kill
the cancer faster than you kill the
patient if you give it to a mouse
who has tumors because their tumor
suppressor has been turned off
and it functions as chemotherapy it may
actually extend their lives making it
seem like this drug is not only not
toxic but it's actually a bit healthy
right which is surprising
so
in any case the long telomeres
create an obvious hazard in our drug
safety system
i assumed that what would happen at the
point that this was revealed is that
there would be
a yes embarrassing but a rapid campaign
to retest all sorts of drugs in light of
things like the vioxx scandal in which
exactly what you would predict if a
toxic drug got through drug safety
testing unfolded and it's not the only
drug
vioxx femphen seldane erythromyce i mean
the list of drugs that do damage that we
did not spot is very long
all the drugs that were tested on these
animals need to be retested i thought
that that was going to happen but the
second reason that this is so
devastating
is that because
mice are what we call model organisms
we build our scientific understanding on
what we see in mice now
everybody knows that they're not perfect
models in fact there are no perfect
models but they are needlessly broken in
this way they do not have to have long
telomeres and even the the reason that
we breed these animals the way we do
is to get a uniform genetic background
which reduces the noise which allows us
to see the effect of treatments and
things
much more easily in these refined
laboratory animals you can still have
that
right you don't need to get long
telomeres it's not a consequence of uh
of inbreeding them we now know
but in any case the point is
damage was done not only to our drug
safety system
but also to our scientific understanding
of how we function because this is our
primary mammal model we stacked a lot of
bad info on top of itself and we you
know that destroys science downstream of
it for decades to come until you finally
fix it and then you got to go back and
say well how many of the things we
believe are true are actually false
because they came primarily from mice
that had been
distorted in this way
all right
so
my point is
we're going to keep it in-house is a
phrase that clues us into how things get
inversely labeled
because
it is true that you can successfully
compete
by being more insightful than others but
being more insightful than others is
difficult and everybody's trying to do
it
another way to be more insightful than
others is to take to compete
successfully to compete successfully is
to
delay
an understanding that others might reach
and if they had it too then we would all
be on a level playing field but if i
know the mice are broken and you don't
know the mice are broken then i'm ahead
in the science game
so the two ways to out-compete other
people are to actually be better or to
engage in sabotage those are your two
categories right and sabotage may be too
narrow a term but but broadly speaking
actually be better actually out compete
at the like we're trying to do x i did x
better than u or
i'm going to get in your way of
accomplishing x of c x of knowing what
is what x is hinging on all of that
stuff over in subterfuge and sabotage
space and um ecologically speaking we
have terms for this
right we have the term exploitation
competition which means i'm going to get
to that flower before you do right i'm
going to get to the nectar and that
means you're going to have less nectar
available to you but that's not i'm not
interfering with your ability to get the
nectar i'm just
more effectively reaching it yeah i got
it and it's zero sum and the nectar's in
me now so there's my left for you
there's none left for you
so that's the kind of competition that
we all expect when we hear you know i'm
going to make a better product and it's
going to mean that the niche in the
market isn't available to you because
everybody's going to want the version
that i built right
um beautiful world right
but then there's this other kind of
competition called interference
competition interference competition is
where instead of elaborating my capacity
to get to the
rare resource i'm going to interrupt
your ability to get there i'm going to
do damage to you so that you can't get
there and yeah at uh at the
weekend bar scenes this is uh known as
[ __ ] blocking
yeah i mean that's a perfect example of
interference competition actually right
like
yes this is the it is it is that so
the the argument i'm trying to
flesh out here is that
uh we all understand the scientific
um
endeavor based on the sort of brochure
understanding of what's supposed to
what's supposed to happen what's
supposed to happen is we are all trying
to be more insightful than everybody
else and those who have special
uh you know insight into the world
come to inhabit the powerful positions
you know they are more influential on
students science gets better over time
as a result of their efforts that's how
it's supposed to work again beautiful
world a beautiful world
but
we neglect the interference competition
and this is you know one of the flaws
with what we call
uh peer review which as we often say
here is not the same thing as review by
peers which is a good thing if you have
peers it's good for them to review your
work but peer review the privately done
thing that prevents your work from ever
seeing the light of day that is another
story entirely
so
what am i getting at
what i'm getting at is
we live in
uh a democracy
right the west is built of democracies
and inside of those democracies we have
markets
we have
capitalism
these are two distinct
modes of thinking really
on the one hand in a in a democracy we
are supposed to all be on the same page
that we want our nations to do well
right so if you think back to the paper
that we first showed right the tension
between how well your lineage or
population does is one way of getting
ahead if your nation is strong that's
good for you
and then the other way of getting ahead
is uh competition within your lineage
right
and so
um
we
because we live in
these
um structures that gather us together we
are supposed to have effectively a
patriotic instinct where we want the we
want science to be more insightful right
and we also want to rise within science
but the problem is these two things are
at cross purposes with each other
and
unfortunately
the
whatever it is that in the
um
in the 21st century
is making us understandable to each
other is polarizing us is dividing us
into teams that are um
that in which the people on the other
team begin to seem
inhuman to you the problem is that
pushes us into a mode where we don't see
our shared interest what we see is our
opportunity to get ahead
and in such a world
we have to ask the question
in whose interest is it to have
an honest-to-goodness newspaper
right one that does the journalistic
work of figuring out what's true
irrespective of how
uh
that makes the people in power feel
right
in whose interest is that if we are
divided into teams and trying to get
ahead i'm trying to get ahead at your
expense right you and i are supposed to
be aligned but if i'm trying to get
ahead at your expense then it is not in
my interest that there be a
public-spirited journalistic
uh establishment that sorts through the
truth
it's also true that just as you said
uh that when people think about
competition what they the thing that is
in their head is exploitation
competition almost always i got the
thing i was i've therefore demonstrated
that i was able to get it um and i am
there for a better competitor as opposed
to all the forms of interference
competition which also include legacy
reasons for having gotten there and all
of this
um
i i'm sorry i just lost the connection
to what you were exactly saying you'll
get it back in just a second
all right so what i was getting at is
there are many institutions
that are failing simultaneously we can
all see it right why are they failing
simultaneously because
they're because the thing that they are
supposed to do is counterproductive for
those who are playing on teams within
our
lineages within our nations right
does
do those who are trying to get ahead at
the expense of others within their
nation within the west within the world
do those who are attempting to do that
want universities to be
engaged in trying to figure out uh what
actually works i mean what would happen
if a university actually figured out
that some generic drug that nobody owns
was the most effective tool we had at
our disposal
against kobe that would get in the way
of you know a huge number of billions of
dollars of potential profits you don't
necessarily want truth-seeking to be a
powerful independent force you want it
to be something else
you know how much do you want uh the
children of your children's competitors
um
how much do you want your children's
competitors to be well educated right
we've been battling uh for our entire
lives over
uh the nature of public education how
much to invest in it what the content
should be part of that may be that we
honestly disagree about what the content
is but part of that are people who can't
say what they're really up to which is
sabotaging
the
intellectual capacity of their
children's competitors
so
this is really the
um the argument is that
we we have a system in which something
doesn't want the truth labeled as truth
because it wants it privatized it's
keeping it in-house
did you remember what you were going to
say yeah but we're past it oh
all right um
so i guess i guess that's the uh
the long and short of it
the conclusion again just to say it
that
um
when you are playing against others
inside of an entity like a nation uh
or a culture or
uh an institution your interest is not
in having the information available to
everybody you're the
your incentive is to privatize as much
of that information as possible and if
you know if you can do it causing people
to have an allergic reaction to the
truth is great because it will blind
them to being able to find uh
the insight that you alone want to
profit from yeah there there it is
that's that's where i thought we were
going um
which is the allergic re
not just
the fact that there seems to be a
non-independent across-the-board set of
conclusions that are in many cases the
opposite of what is true
and that in itself should
trigger people to think that's not
likely so you know what what single or a
couple of data points you know was no
rather sources of of
stories of scientific stories really did
those things come from
uh but also
okay so you've got a whole lot of people
believing the opposite of what is true
but it's it's worse than that it's it's
a kind of
it's a kind of cognitive autoimmunity
where
you've got people
actually allergic to the truth
not just believing something that is
that is wrong but when the when the true
thing is pointed out um this this has
been done well enough
uh that the actual truth feels dangerous
feels um feels scandalous
feels like those people who say such
things must be barbarians of some sort
and of course we should all always try
to keep the barbarians at the gate so
there is there's this
this tension of like explicitly
tribalistic thinking at many many
different levels where at each point
that someone will begin to say wait um
i'm not sure about that
what what will happen to them is they
will be triggered to be reminded like oh
no if you got to think like us
or else we may not be able to protect
you anymore
or you know you definitely don't want to
be on the outside of science
and you know for those of us who are
saying actually a bunch of scientists us
included are saying that's not science
and anyone who tells you to follow the
science has just revealed that they
don't know what science is
well for the vast majority of people
including especially i think
those who see themselves as educated
because they have degrees that claim
that make the claim that they are
educated
most people didn't ever do any science
and to the extent that they did it was
probably taught badly because teaching
science especially to people who aren't
majoring in science is not a priority at
our universities at all it's not it's
very very rarely done well
it's even more true
um
well in some ways it's more true sort of
the younger the the kids you're talking
about teaching
so
you have a vast educated class who
knows as i've said this many times
before knows that they are
innumerate knows that they can't do math
and they're almost proud of that
but the idea that also they don't really
know what science is and at the point
that people show up saying that thing
that we arrived at that we are told that
was arrived at by extraordinarily rapid
behind closed doors consensus and that's
the science and now you have to just go
with the science
doesn't sound like science
many too many people
with this autoimmune autocognitive
autoimmunity uh which is exactly what
you have just walked us through
will say oh no no
now now you've gone too far i know that
now what you're doing is putting me in
danger and and putting me at risk of
basically stepping outside of of the
bounds of
you know respectable conversation and
cocktail party talk um the people who
claim to be scientists because i can
tell because they've got glassware
you know what what whatever the
indicators are right now and really at
some level we're also back to fashion
right this is the it is in part like
well i'm going to look around and see
what other people are doing oh
everyone's everyone's following the
science i guess i'll follow the science
and when some scientists stand up and
say
no
say well but you're not where are your
flasks
where's your lab coat
and and so people look for the
indicators as opposed to i'm going to
have to actually do the work and think
about the technical details or was their
hypothesis or how was that funded where
were the incentives
what's the background what was that
based on do mice actually have long
telomeres or not right so uh it's the
trappings of science and something you
know and i i will just say i'm agnostic
about how much consciousness was
involved in this system right there's
clearly a degree of self-assembly of
this system but that's the i mean that's
the wonder of selection right i mean
that's that's exactly true you know
right needs there needs to have been no
conspiracy that doesn't suggest that
there was no conspiracy but it doesn't
require it there will have look
there are little conspiracies all the
time right uh
inside of corporations inside of
departments inside of
newsrooms right people decide what
they're going to report what they're not
going to report
they're supposed to be a sort of north
star of what you're doing and the
problem is if you follow the north star
of science what happens to you well you
probably don't make it through graduate
school right it's very dangerous for you
if you exhibit too much independence and
a willingness to point out what's wrong
with the thinking of people who are too
powerful
so
you know what happens if you set up a
selective system like that is the people
who end up with the lab coats and the
you know the chairs of departments and
you know the endowed chairs and the
awards and all of those things the
people who are in those positions are
specifically the ones who are good at
the social game of science of science
uh but not inherently good at thinking
scientifically or behaving like a
scientist when uh it's awkward for power
and that's the skill sets may in fact um
not be
be unlikely to be found coincident with
one another yeah they're in management
of the modern scientific bureaucracy and
thinking
carefully scientifically logically
thoroughly such that you will often find
that actually something that you've
based a bunch of experiments on you're
going to have to undo you're going to
have to stop that and do this over here
there's there's going to be a lot of
reasons that you don't necessarily find
that those two things in the same person
right and it wasn't always that way i'm
sure there was always a degree of that
right there have always been people
who've been good at the social system um
and were you know we're less good at
science but the problem is something has
flipped the incentives so that to be
good at science means that you're very
unlikely to succeed in what we call by
that name
and
that results in a predicament that i you
know i have some sympathy for the public
here the public
cannot fathom how it could be that all
of the people right that the entire
medical profession could get something
wrong i mean that's one thing if nobody
knows but if the answer is available and
the entire medical profession gets it
wrong that suggests something dire has
occurred which it has
what is the dire thing
something has started
let's put it this way
things like science
and democracy
are extremely dangerous to power right
if you have power
you can lose power right
having a democracy that can elect people
whose allegiances you don't know in
advance that's very dangerous to power
having science that can discover that
something that you're doing is actually
very dangerous or that there's a much
better way to do what it is that you're
profiting from that would be much less
destructive right having science
empowered to do that is very dangerous
to power and so the idea is one thing
you might find amongst
those who have accumulated great power
is a reluctance about these very systems
that threaten them right journalism
science
public-spirited
regulation
democracy all of these things
are the whole reason that they're good
is that they're indifferent to power and
so it's not surprising that power would
begin to take aim at them and it would
say well you know of course we love
science i mean look at all the
technology
that is uh born from science but why do
we want to share it with everybody right
that's that's the question right so
actually now that i think about it um
we do not expect
our
military
to be interested in sharing its finest
weapons technology
openly right
we expect our military to want to keep
an advantage that comes from being ahead
in terms of the technology of the
weaponry and what i'm really arguing is
that that very same thing has happened
inside of places where it's explicitly
not supposed to right well and uh
obviously facilitated like how could you
possibly reverse that trend at the point
that
euphemistic public-private partnerships
become the law of the land you know at
the point
that our publicly funded research
including both basic research which is
to say research that does not have a
clear applied
reason to exist
but also including the research that
maybe is trying to do drug discovery
right that at the point that all of our
publicly funded research
much of it is now in like active
explicit cahoots
with trying to find private partnerships
because that's where the money comes
from
you have
you have spoiled something that you had
no right to spoil and however many
however many stories you tell yourself
about how great that is that now we've
got more money coming in for research
that needs to be done the fact is
that public funding of research has an
ability at least in theory to steer
clear of the profit motive that
private corporations cannot because
that's why they exist yeah actually i i
think you've you've nailed it um that
the public-private partnerships are
fundamentally flawed because although it
is true that a private entity benefits
from science
advancing the ball it it succeeds better
when the outgrowth is not publicly
shared
and
that that that's a fundamental conflict
in terms of the objective public
spiritedness
is effectively dying in front of us and
the institutions are doing exactly what
you would expect them to do if you just
simply remove the public spiritedness
and therefore allowed
rent seeking to dominate them
and the trouble is that it also plays
into
um
this issue of the big lie
that although everybody kind of gets
that something isn't right with the
institutions it's almost impossible to
believe that they're just that the
things that they say are misinformation
are actually information yeah right what
are the chances of that well the answer
is the chances are good because of
evolution and market forces and
uh
game theory but if you're not expert in
those things you may think well all
right uh i'm sure there's a lot of
nonsense in those institutions but they
they couldn't possibly be that wrong
indeed
okay we've got three more topics we've
already been going for an hour
so
um you also wanted to talk about
why we are angry at the wrong people
well in light of the fact that we've
been going an hour maybe we should hold
that one hold that one yeah all right
uh we will we'll just gray that out and
come back to it how about
oh actually don't gray it out oh how
would it look if we if we blew it up
gonna blew it up all right i don't know
i tried
very briefly before we go on to talking
about fatherhood which will be the final
final segment of today's show
baby formula which so there is as
everyone knows a baby formula shortage
which probably presages a you know
everything shortage which is coming down
the pike at us itself a conversation for
another time we're not coming down the
turnpike get us sailing as a result of
yes diesel so you're about to have
nothing coming down the pike at you and
be happy
own nothing be happy yes uh well if you
find yourself in possession of a baby as
we do not
and also find yourself uh unable to
produce enough milk for your baby and
this i have not been paying much
attention to the baby formula thing in
particular because
uh
too often
the reason i as i have understood is the
reason that people need baby formula is
because they're choosing not to
breastfeed and that that should not be a
choice that feels natural or normal to
people that babies babies do best on
breast milk they just do however there
are lots of situations actually and
probably these are accelerated
um or and or entirely created by
modernity but everything from preemies
to uh you know other conditions that
cause a mother to
want to breastfeed to produce breast
milk but not enough for their child
means that in some cases there will need
to be something that is not
breast milk that babies are getting fed
um also
adoption
also adoption als also um yeah adoption
uh not
lesbian parents when one of the women
gestated
but um gay male parents right so yeah
lots lots of situations in which you're
in possession of a baby
and uh and you need something and you
can't produce it from your own body
but prefab formula is is gross and i i
never looked into it really but just
like most of the alternative
quote-unquote milks out there
uh made from various nuts are actually
just filled with gums and and seed oils
and all sorts of fillets basically to
stabilize them or else no one would
drink them if if you just ground up a
bunch of nuts and uh put it on a
supermarket shelf and let it sit for a
week or two they would you know separate
and then start to go rancid very quickly
excuse me um so formula has this problem
but in some ways even more so and of
course it's more important that formula
if that's what you have to be feeding
your baby
be free and clear of all of that crap
the additives the fillers the gums the
you know the seed oils
then you know the older you are the
better you can withstand some amount of
insult in the form of toxicity to your
body
so a friend of mine naturopath uh dr
danny lockwood
uh on her website and it was actually
and so these are these are two new
friends of ours um danielle is the
naturopath and her husband richard uh
when their lovely child was born zach
you can show me uh show me you can show
my screen if you will um when their
lovely child was born
three years ago
uh they found that danny couldn't
produce as much milk as she as she
wanted she says this i'm not giving away
any stories here and richard uh went and
uh
produced a formula for formula that
doesn't have all the crap in it so
formula formula a formula formula uh
that is that is here and so i'm just
going to link to this in the show notes
i'm not going to walk through why he's
used all of it or you know or or any of
that but just say we have since met this
child um you know not when she was a
baby three-year-old and she is a
charming healthy smart amazing child and
uh and you know lots of kids are who got
fed crap but uh but certainly would be
better if you didn't and
i
i just wanted to share
that if you find yourself in the
position of not producing enough milk
for a child that you need to um that you
need to feed and is too young to be
eating other things uh that this is a
this is a really good possibility right
now i haven't looked at this uh i assume
it's good stuff we obviously
can't know for sure but really the point
is does it out compete store-bought
stuff
which it is almost certain to and you
know every expectation it's it's very
high quality but
um exactly
um
there was something else to
say there zach may have my screen back
thank you um i guess the one other thing
that i was going to say is i'm i was
reminded when i was thinking about this
and i looked through and i actually just
noticed you know sunflower oil is on
there i probably wouldn't use sunflower
oil i'd use avocado oil or
olive or something
um
but i was reminded of a line that had
jumped out of me when i was reading the
road to wigan pier the george orwell
book that we talked about back in boy
episodes 117 and 118.
and the line
that was one
that i did not share when we were
talking about the book back in march was
this is from orwell we may find in the
long run that tinned food is a deadlier
weapon than the machine gun
he as in so many things was prescient
and one of the reasons that this
this particular
conclusion of his struck me is that it
is
a perfect analogy for the for much of
modernity and for the fact that when
it's active physical force
you can see it it's obvious there's no
denying it who's going to claim it's not
dangerous you know obviously obviously
it's like a machine gun it's understood
to be a weapon
whereas once it has the label on it that
says
this is a lifesaver this is going to
help you out this is going to increase
your convenience this is going to save
you time it's going to make your life
better
it's much harder for people to conclude
actually
that may be the wolf in sheep's clothing
i'd rather just have the wolf thank you
very much so that i can see it and maybe
i'll still make that choice but i really
want to know what it is that i'm
accepting
and you know certainly most formula most
baby formula is like that
most of these you know everything from
alternative milks but i just found i
forgot to send you zack but i just found
in the aisles of one of these just
excellent we have such excellent um
grocery stores here in in portland and
yet even in one of our excellent grocery
stores i found
canned raisin bread
which
i thought
i know there's no need for canned raisin
bread
right i i am 100 certain of this
and some people will presumably pull it
off the shelf not as a joke and uh
open up a can of bread
pour it out but what happens next it's
almost worth buying a can just to find
out
what's in there what happens when you
open it up it's snakes or something
but uh anyway the idea that again to
quote or well we may find the long run
that tinned food is a deadlier weapon
than the machine gun
just extraordinary it's the things that
you have been told are good for you it's
the things that you're being told are
going to make your life easier it's the
things that you're being told have
solved the problems that humans have
been dealing with forever
really so we know now that things like
modern orthodontia and
giving children babies only very soft
food to chew on and uh high sugar drinks
because we love it and it tastes good
well that makes our teeth rot so i just
came up with three things that are about
dentistry but it's all over the place
and we talk about in our book and 100
gatherers guide to the 21st century
some of the
just some
some of the liners intend in in the
canning process when you're doing it in
for mass production are now understood
to be these you know
to be causing long-term effects now
that's quite different from saying
actually i'm going to put up a bunch of
my my fresh produce that i grew or that
i bought at the farmer's market at home
and keep an eye on it and make sure that
i know what it looks like
if you know if if it ended up not being
fully preserved but pulling a jar of
your own homemade jam or pickled
asparagus or whatever it is off your
shelf that you made with ingredients
that you know and without anything that
you can't pronounce is quite different
from saying okay well if it's canned
it's canned if i canned it or if procter
and gamble candidate it must be the same
thing well no yeah in part because you
have very different incentives you have
very different incentives and it's very
you know it's
it's a version of the demarcation
problem where you don't know you know
canned peaches aren't as good as peaches
but
they are fruit that you can have in the
winter right so it might be better than
not having them right right
um
in glass is going to be better than in
metal
right assuming
the right kind of glass not a leaded
glass which of course you wouldn't be
able to buy in a canning context but the
point is at what point
have you modified it enough that an
alarm bell should go off and each little
step might not be the step you know
there's some straw that breaks the
camel's back but which one is it yes um
but
the you know
canned anything including if you think
back to the conversation we were just
having
canned perspectives are in in some way
the same thing right maybe that's what
was in the canned raisin bread
perspectives
well you know it's a little bit you know
what is the new york times like it's a
perspective canner now it was a
newspaper and it's become a perspective
canner and the point is if you want to
be
comforted about the
new gender chaos you can you can have it
in your canned perspective right along
with your
sense about who the science cranks are
and who the the uh the proper
authorities are right it's all and how
just simple yeah everything exactly it's
all prepared and you know it goes to it
goes to ukraine it goes to gender
ideology it goes to covid it goes it
goes everywhere right it goes everywhere
and the point is it comes with
uh
hidden costs that are nowhere
described right the hazard to you of
accepting the canned perspective
is tremendous just the same way
you know accepting
food that's soft because it's convenient
may cause you to need thousands of
dollars of orthodontia and then tens of
thousands of dollars of implants um down
the road right the point is that the
hazard is actually quite large but it
sure doesn't feel it you know and you
know
just simply having something that's too
soft doesn't
cause you to have these you know the
point is it's the displacing of the
stuff that would properly cause your jaw
to form
in a robust way
um
okay
uh well from
from breast milk and fake breast milk to
fathers to fathers
right yeah
so again like like i said near the top
of the hour father's day is tomorrow and
yesterday we attended the graduation of
zachary our
firstborn and our producer along with
his three living grandparents
and uh
it was it was quite a spectacle
and it
that and some previous things that we
had been thinking about caused us to
want to say a few things about
fatherhood yes i did want to correct one
thing you said tomorrow is father's day
um
every day is father's day that's my
feeling is that right yes which means
that father's day is earth day um and
the earth shall be ours love your
father something um
yeah i did want to
yeah
for some reason that your your idea of
you know
taking over everything
father's taking over everything which is
which is obviously a joke at one level
it's like the stereotype of what the the
men would do if they were allowed access
to all the holidays
um and actually they wouldn't but this
is like this is like a like a washington
post version of what they think the men
would do if they were allowed to take
over all the holidays um but you're like
you know every day is father's day
reminds me of
the paint company that actually makes
extraordinary paint but has the worst
logo that i've really ever seen and i'm
not going to name the company but i will
say that the logo is an earth with a
paint can over it pouring over the earth
and it says cover the earth cover the
earth yes it's such an abomination and
it's really hard to continue loving the
paint but it's just really high quality
paint but no please don't cover the
earth please no every day is not
father's day
and you don't want to do that anyway no
no i just i thought i'd put in a word
for the patriarchy while i was at it
sure you know i mean what else right
exactly um i mean every day is
patriarchy day let's agree on that yeah
now some of us have noticed okay yeah i
did actually have a serious point i know
um moments ago and it was about uh
something this has actually been um
troubling to me for
a couple decades there's there's a
terminology we use
out here in civilization that seems to
me so upside down
and what it is is
when we say that somebody you know is
your biological father right what we
mean
is that they are your genetic father
but the problem and you know you'll even
hear this in courts right the discussion
about custody and things that you know
who is your biological father but here's
what is completely misunderstood about
this
human beings are as we described very
thoroughly in our book human beings are
a very unusual species in which a huge
fraction of what we are and in fact
almost all of the important stuff is in
the cognitive software layer not in the
hardware layer
and we have also described and done so
on the podcast many times
that human males have two reproductive
strategies or two broad categories and
we have described this variously as
three
versions but let's just say you've got a
demarcation between a high investment
strategy in which males
invest symmetrically to females in the
raising of offspring
they're protecting and providing for
them and then males also have other
options which involve no investment in
in offspring
and the problem with the terminology
about somebody's biological father is
that it treats all of the stuff that
fathers actually do the stuff that
matters most as somehow
secondary and lesser and unimportant
when in fact it is primary and every bit
as biological in other words
we our genes
create a brain that is inhabited by
our uh
our our
uh
trying to avoid the term mind but that's
really what i mean here our minds
develop inside our brains
the mind is what the brain does
and that mind is shaped by the exposure
that a person has
while developing
right somebody who
provides the genes that become you but
doesn't stick around doesn't inform you
is not an important part of your
developmental environment is your father
in one way
but it is not the important way
right the genes aren't that remarkable
they're not so different between one
individual and another what is
remarkable what's important is what you
become
and what you become is not preordained
in the genetic layer it is something
that happens uh better when you have a
father present and it doesn't matter
whether that father is your genetic
parent or not so
first thing to say is i really would
love us to break the habit of referring
to
[Music]
your genetic parent as your biological
parent your biological parent is
the person who raised you every bit as
much as it is the person who provided
uh the genes in question it's great if
they're the same person
oftentimes for many people they are not
the same person and we should not be
denigrating the role of somebody who has
been your biological father in the
cultural cognitive sense but wasn't your
genetic parent because it really is the
primary place uh where
where being a father is difficult and
where the content of fatherhood matters
yeah at some level uh this is a place
where uh the sexes are once again
different and this is asymmetrical with
regard to
a genetic mother
putting aside a few modern ways that
that can happen a genetic mother has
actually by virtue of her being the
genetic mother and especially if she's
gonna continue to raise the child um put
in a tremendous amount of resource and
labor um through gestation and lactation
right whereas the genetic father
has uh only had to contribute sperm and
that was presumably quite a bit of fun
and not much work right so
the act of actually parenting
of mothering
or fathering
to you know to turn it into the verb
form
is
by far the you know the larger part of
the work and the more um you know the
more rewarding in many ways and
you know it just goes on and on and on
and on
but um the genetic part of motherhood
has already been a substantial
investment
which the genetic part of fatherhood has
not been and so
uh
so thinking about fatherhood is only you
know only the sperm did you did you or
did you not
uh minimizes tremendously what all
fatherhood can be
as too would considering uh motherhood
only to be the the pregnancy and the and
the lactation the breastfeeding would be
to minimize all of what motherhood is
but that's already a big piece like that
the gestational lactation are already
providing a bond
and a lifelong attachment
that under you know almost all normal
conditions then you know then maintains
forever
and one
one i think
issue here because you know
we hear things like oh
um you think the definition of woman is
so simple you know it's an adult human
female but definitions change all the
time look at how we talk about an
adoptive father being a father and he's
not a father you know this is sort of
where this is coming from right yep and
i think one
i don't you know you can't change
language by dictat or when people try it
usually backfires
but
as much as the conversation right now
around sex and gender is very confused
by a lot of people including some people
who are trying to make it confused and
including by some people who are trying
to make sense of it but just
don't don't necessarily have the tools
what you and i have been saying for a
long time since since long before any of
this was in the cultural
conversation was
sex is the hardware and um you know
including a bunch of pieces and gender
is the software or i would say gender is
the behavior the behavioral
manifestations right and i think you
know those two things
apply somewhat less well in different
particular situations
so
um woman refers to sex
but you can act you know woman lee or
feminine or you know turn that into an
adjective
and and say well now we're talking about
ways that historically traditionally
stereotypically if you like women have
tended to act
women actual women who would do or did
or will or would produce eggs right but
for genetic or developmental anomalies
women have tended to act in ways that
are
more nurturing
women have tended to act have tended to
be more interested in people and animals
than in things or systems
not all women not all men aren't
interested etc etc etc we don't have to
make those caveats all the time or at
least we shouldn't have to
but we have these two different words
and as much as it seems very confusing
right now it is useful to have those two
different words sex is
the you know sex refers to what the
genetics handed us
and gender is all of the downstream
effects some of which are much more
variable
but we only have one word for father
and so part of part of what we're
running into then is almost the inverse
of
the problem that we're having with sex
and gender like maybe we want two words
i don't think we actually do precisely
because
the genetic contribution to fatherhood
isn't that big a deal compared to all of
the other things that good fathers do
so um i have a thought experiment i use
to pressure test this to see whether
whether i actually believe it um
and it works like this
suppose
um suppose i found so zach is sitting
here yes he is um you're his father i am
his father let's suppose that i was not
his genetic father and that i just
discovered that now this runs into an
immediate complication right obviously
if your spouse cheats on you and that's
how you end up raising uh
somebody else's genetic product as your
own offspring then
the breach of trust in the relationship
is so gargantuan that it's hard to
separate out your emotions about the kid
yeah but let's say it was a switched at
birth
can i interrupt for a second sure
and just say um
just just in case you guys are wondering
this is autobiographical at all um the
six of us your parents my mother you and
i and zachary were sitting at dinner
last night before zach's graduation
before we went to zac's graduation
and he embarked zachary embarked on some
stories about um how he had gotten
through school and how he had driven and
how he had managed to
obtain some vehicles legally but
by stretching boundaries and pushing
limits and i also stretch boundaries and
push limits but
every single thing about the way that he
was talking the way his
mind was clearly moving and his facial
expressions and i looked at you and your
two parents and said i know you didn't
wonder but if you ever did wonder now
you should have no doubt as to the
paternity of this child well i i hate to
to do this so publicly but what i never
say in these circumstances but always
think is well
you know
i was the parent who raised him so you
would expect that these things would be
that way whether or not i mean you know
there could be a genetic component even
though there was pressure from both of
us for him not to do some of those
things
oh right yeah no no like don't follow
down your father's footsteps here that's
just no one to trouble not zachary
not terribly surprised but okay the
pressure test though let's say it was a
switched at birth at the hospital thing
right so that
you and i both discover uh he's not
actually our kid
right
does it change how i feel about him
not in the slightest not in the
slightest what if you discovered it two
days later
well two days later yeah you know you
reverse the thing
um
but
at this point
he's my kid yep whether or not let me
use my genetic kid
and
here's the here's the place where the
pressure test doesn't 100 work okay am i
indifferent to the kid that was our
genetic kid that got swapped out of the
hospital and we've never met him yeah
curious
i'm curious yeah right what's he like
i'm curious and i might even
feel affection uh
towards him
but
no the i'm this guy's father
one way or the other genetically
speaking right and that becomes
biologically speaking one way or the
other biologically speaking known one
way or the other genetically speaking
whether he's my genetic kid or not my
genetic kid my feeling about him is the
same and my role as his father is the
same
right um and
uh you know that's not to say that genes
don't play some role that there aren't
some surprising heritable
characteristics but by and large they
have been
uh greatly overrated compared to the
huge
uh range of things that an actual father
passes on to their kid um that are not
passed you know i mean look like how to
be a total pain in the ass like how to
be a total pain in the ass
yeah you did that really well thank you
um how not to pass up a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity at a pun
no matter how inappropriate it is to
make it at that moment yeah i guess
that's sort of a subsidiary lesson i've
had to be opinionated yeah but i just
think yeah yeah um but how not to think
hierarchically no actually zach does
that really well
he does that best
sorry that was a subtle
not very funny joke although i enjoyed
it um but
uh yeah anyway so i i think i think
we've more or less arrived at the point
which is let's fix our damn terminology
and let's
uh you know you're right motherhood
clears this up because it is so very
rare um that there is any you know
ambiguity by virtue of the intensity of
the relationship formed by pregnancy and
lactation
um
but
well i mean there are plenty of mothers
who aren't genetic mothers but it is a
rarer phenomenon right
um it's a rarer phenomenon and uh
anyway we could do better terminology
wise and i hope that especially i would
almost think that the courts should
start by fixing this and that the
culture can catch up
well i guess um this isn't exactly about
fatherhood and father's day but my my
natural selection is my substance that
will drop on tuesday
is actually about
issues around this a little bit uh and
so i will just
preview it slightly i believe it was
last week i said something i don't
remember what what we would have been
talking about but i said something that
i say a lot
which is that every human being has an
equal number of male and female
ancestors and almost whenever i say that
someone uh says no that's not true i
know we've got lots more female
ancestors than we do male ancestors
and so i will just leave this teaser and
say both things are true
it depends on whether or not you're
thinking about the individual or the
population and most people who are
walking around especially if you're
anything basically but an evolutionary
biologist
or an ecologist are not ever thinking in
terms of populations and so when you
hear something like oh we've got way
more female ancestors than male
ancestors you assume you put into that
sentence oh that must be about
individuals without even in any way
being conscious even maybe having the
framework for knowing that there would
be a distinction
but what i've written about hopefully
pretty cleanly and clearly to be able to
point to forever after in this piece
that'll be coming up in three days on
natural selections
is you know how it is that we know that
this is true for individuals that each
of us has an equal number of male and
female ancestors while it is also true
that the population level um there are
more females than males in our in our
history uh so both things are true even
though if you say either thing
uncarefully it sounds like you're
directly contradicting the other and you
know this is this is
for me for us some of the fun of but
also for other people coming in the
nuance the complications some of the
frustration with evolutionary thinking
and frankly getting your brain around a
few of these little tweaks
is you know if it will it will help
everyone make sense of your world better
and if for instance the people running
some of the uh three-letter
organizations had a better sense of some
of these um complexities i think would
be in um much better shape
yeah if they're even if they're even
trying
right
all right anything else um
no
i mentioned the
podcast episodes that people should
check out
you did uh i
uh
said that i was gonna come back with the
actual name of abigail's book uh and i
will also put it in the show notes you
had it right it's irreversible damage
the transgender craze seducing our
daughters
uh it's excellent i recommend it i also
recommend her and my interchange
which came out before her book was
published about a
little little less than a year before
her book was published on the same topic
and
we will take a little break here and
then for those of you
watching are watching live in about 15
minutes we will come back with a q a you
can ask questions for that at
darkersubmissions.com
and until we see you again this time
next week we encourage you to be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside
happy father's day
[Music]
you